Christian du hast dich ja mega
gestritten mit den Grünen die Frage ist
jetzt wie kannst du das klein reden mit
einer griffigen Metapher wir sind eine
Regierung ist ein fun fact Klasse wo
gehämmert klingt sehr nach Werkstatt
jetzt geschraubt wird ja das klingt als
wä die Regierung Montageservice für
Möbel das führt zu Geräuschen nee
mexikanischer boheneintopf und 2 ler
Bier derf zu Geräuschen Olaf Scholz
vielleicht noch mal ein anderer versuch
das ganze in der Metapher einzuordnen
die nicht aus dem Baumarkt ist wir
werden Hämmern und Klopfen ja klar aber
mit Schalldämpfer ja und dazu haben wir
dann technische Möglichkeiten wo das
Hämmern und Klopfen stattfindet aber
weniger laut bei Ihnen ankommt ich
glaube nicht dass Olaf Scholz am Anfang
seines Satzes schon wusste wie er endet
für ihn immer wieder aufregend also
übersetzt wenn gestritten wird dann nur
so dass niemand von außen es merkt warum
soll eine Regierung was anderes sein als
eine Familienfeier